So, in this lesson, what patterns are we going to learn? Well, we'll learn about
filtering patterns, we'll learn about summarization patterns,
and something we'll call structural patterns. And
these are all just frameworks for using
MapReduce for solve problems that you've probably
encountered as a programmer before. Filtering patterns
solve filtering problems. Like, sampling data, or,
maybe even generating some top-n list. Maybe,
top ten something. Summarization patterns solve summarization problems. Getting
a high-level view of your data. Things like counting records. Finding
min and max, then calculating basic statistical values, like
mean, median, and mode. We can also use these patterns to create
an index, finally, these structural patterns will solves structural
problems. And, the one more focus on, in this
lesson, is combining two data sets. And, just to
warn you, this lesson will go fast, and, that
means you probably won't remember everything about all of
these patterns. Totally okay, not expected. The point of
this lesson, is for you to know that these
patterns exist. And that if you ever find yourself
in a situation with big data where you say this problem is really just a
filtering or a summarization problem. You'll know where
to look, to find a technique to solve.